they keep turning up on the Obama
administration's intelligence officers
after the release of the Miller report
showed no signs of collusion GOP
leadership now demanding answers on why
the investigation was started in the
first place and when and what the Obama
team knew regarding Russia's
interference in our 2016 election here's
Senator Lindsey Graham did they'd
exonerate Clinton because they had a
political bias did they ignoring all the
facts because that they indict her they
know she can't beat Trump and they
weren't a trump to lose it was the
counterintelligence investigation a
backdoor way of spying on Trump there's
real no evidence of working with Russia
they just used an excuse John Brennan
who was the head of the CIA at the time
went on to become one of trumps most
vocal critics and heavily pushed these
collusion claims he was asked about that
yesterday I know if I received been
efficient but I think I suspected that
there was more than there actually was
and here's former Director of National
Intelligence James clapper on whether he
regrets attacking President Trump will
also deflecting responsibility for the
Russian interference I do have concerns
about the and the president's
unwillingness or inability or whatever
to call out the Russian interference in
the election the one of President
Obama's objectives in tasking us to do
that report on the Russian interference
was to hand it off to the next
administration so the Trump
administration would have that as as a
basis for taking action against Russia
which sort of hasn't happened and in
some ways counselor to the president
Kellyanne Conway blasting these Obama
officials earlier today those people at
the DOJ and the FBI at the time they
have besmirched the good reputations and
integrity of the 25 or 35,000 men and
women who work in that department and do
their jobs
honorably the Obama administration and
the president self knew that Russia was
trying to interfere in our election and
did nothing about it and when the
president was asked earlier if he
thought the decision to investigate made
it all the way to the West Wing of the
Obama White House here's what he said I
don't want to say that but I think you
know the answer all right Jesse do you
know the answer
yes it was Obama anything else deep
state I got this let's say this was not
an intelligence failure like a WMD or
9/11 this was an intelligence plot that
was foiled what's so funny one even Greg
said deep state you know everybody was
mocking the deep state phrase for the
last two years and now I'm totally
vindicated how's that because one there
was no collusion Oh anytime you said the
word deep State we were laughed at
everything a conspiracy but yes who the
conspiracy theorist was your side this
is what it was the Obama administration
they weren't trying to catch Russians
interfering with the election they were
trying to catch Trump officials
colluding with Russians to interfere
with the election this was a democratic
administration that used the CIA and the
FBI to attack a Republican presidential
campaign it all started with Hillary and
the dossier as many as four Trump
officials were illegally surveilled and
contacted by the CIA and then when she
lost they used this as an insurance
policy to reverse the election results
Trump caught wind of it fired Comey and
was totally vindicated and the only way
the media now can vindicate themselves
if they start putting resources into
actually investigating what went wrong
instead of trying to you know brush it
off and say let's move on let me tell
you how deep state this deep state is
the ghosts of Obama came out of the
Lincoln Bedroom and he's the one that
fired James Comey he's the one that
started this criminal investigation as
opposed to the counterintelligence and
by counterintelligence investigation
began under Obama's warrant crooked
veteran and in other words you wouldn't
have had Muller
unless Trump fired Comey they had
nothing to do with any deep State
nothing to do with though you wouldn't
have had Comey investigating Trump if it
wasn't for the dossier Oh
what came first the chicken or the egg
well hopefully we can get that answer
today listen I add up everybody at this
table I actually disagree with you
slightly on that this not being a 911 or
wd failure from the intelligence
community I think it is of that level
and I speak as someone I've been in the
intelligence community since I was like
25 years only think 26 years old and one
of the things that you're taught as an
analyst when you come in is what were
the failures the analytic failures that
happened leading up to 9/11 and and W&D
and how did we miss all of this and what
I have suspected for a long time is
these leaders of the FBI and the CIA and
the DNI they forgot the basic analytic
lessons that you learn as a junior
analyst when this there was definitely a
lot of red flags there for sure there is
red flags because of what the Russians
were doing and it was the Russians that
were trying to infiltrate so they see
all of this malign behavior from the
Russians they see a lot of red flags and
because of a lack of fully looking at
the evidence they jump to analytic
conclusions about the president that I
think are one of the most damaging
things that any of us have ever seen in
our lifetime let's not you know
sugarcoat this they accuse the president
of treason without having evidence to
back it up and and as a person who has
spent my life and the intelligence
community is so damning to the men and
women who faithfully who are patriots
who go and try to do this work every day
and I think the stain that the American
public has for the intelligence
community because of this these
unethical political leaders can't be
discounted my point was not that this
wasn't a huge intelligence failure to
the level of WMD or 9/11 I'm saying that
were those were innocent mistakes and
lapses this was a devious plot hatched
two years ago and now exposed that's the
den yes does he should he be held to a
higher standard of commentary than your
run-of-the-mill pundit yes he's a CIA
agent he was yes and he said oh whoops
how do you it's because people believed
we're in they were believing a
hallucination and this is why I like as
a deep snakes deep state cynic who is no
longer a deep state cynic you have to
understand that there were a group of
people who felt that they were so right
that they could do they could actually
be undercover that they could do sneaky
things because they were saving the
world they in their heads they were
superheroes but they were actually deep
state because they were doing the wrong
thing but they didn't think they were
doing the wrong thing and the long-term
damage here I mean the big story is
we've did there's a lot of damage
between people and nations because of
this there were people who expected
nothing less than war over this or
taking out a president who might be
taking out removing a president because
he might be a Russian agent that's how
far the hallucination got that's why
people when they laugh at the deep state
it's because they thought that they were
doing right when when you're wearing a
black hat you think you're wearing a
white hat that's essentially what's
going on but I have to you know Jesse's
right the deeps they've existed they
just didn't know they were deep state
but but I don't get it
the president says that Muller acted
honorably and most active state we wait
a minute mother a moment ago was deep
state now he's not deep state is all
about been dead a few kidding you didn't
you missed what Trump had to say about
Muller Muller was involved with Comey
Comey was involved and that was our FBI
key this is such about that we've gone
now from Trump doing a victory lap to
vindictive action we're not we're not
talking about Muller we're talking